let me tell you a secret wars are being
fought for your attention and today
we're gonna be looking at the new war
that's been going on as well as looking
back to see what we can learn from past
Wars the new battlefield is on YouTube
and it involves one really annoying
tactic
[Music]
welcome to the excitement Wars where
fake excitement and hype draws in more
viewers and gets people to watch longer
if you want to be a part of this you
have to get excited like really excited
in fact if they think you're going to
have a seizure or heart attack that's
about the right level but even though
that will get views I don't think fake
excitement is a good thing it eventually
makes excitement and hype on YouTube
meaningless because everyone is
overusing it but I'm not gonna hate on
any individual they're just playing the
system exploiting a weakness in our
attention I just want to talk about the
potential effects and what we can do
about it because believe it or not we've
already seen this war play out before
twice both of them bear striking
resemblances to the excitement Wars and
I think we can examine them to learn
lessons about our own wars today have
you ever heard of the loudness wars it
started in the 1940s when sound
engineers began to realize that louder
music stands out on jukeboxes so they
began telling the record labels to
record louder so people started over
using compressors to artificially raise
the volume of their whole song to be as
loud as possible and the reason raising
the volume artificially matters is
because it destroys something called
dynamic range basically that's the
difference between the quietest and
loudest part of a song and is hugely
responsible for conveying emotion and
tone the problem with the loudness wars
is as Matt Mayfield puts it when there's
no quiet there can be no loud the first
few seconds of Beethoven's fifth
symphony illustrates this really well
pay close attention to the volume and
how it affects the tone of the piece
[Music]
the reason you can really feel those
loud moments is because of the quiet
ones right before it and we can see
these peaks and valleys of intensity in
the visual wave form of a song here's a
song before that loudness Wars really
escalated and here's a waveform during
the loudness Wars simultaneously as the
loudness Wars were going on there was a
similar war going on in the media a war
of sensationalism with Fox News being
one of the first 24-hour news networks
founded in 1996 people soon became aware
that sensationalist even partisan shows
got a lot more views than moderate
even-handed ones because of this several
similar news programs were created on
the other side of the aisle both sides
buying for the attention of the
television viewer this escalation in
sensationalism resulted in news clips
like this this does this offends you
this word a lot of people are shocked
the massive gas line Rutgers could it
happen and no one critiqued the dangers
of this hyper sensationalism better than
John Stewart everything we hear nothing
sounds a little bit like Matt may film
he echoes this thought later in an
interview now the problem is how do you
keep people watching it Oh Jay is not
gonna kill someone every day so that's
gone so what do you have to do you have
to elevate the passion of everything
else that happens that might even be
somewhat mundane and elevate it to the
extent that this is breaking news the
aggregate effect of that is that you
begin to lose the lexicon you begin to
lose any meaning of what breaking news
means or urgent or look at this or
dangerous you know this is a in arms
race the language then has to become
sharper louder to cut through more and
more of the noise and what I'm saying is
maybe
there is a way to not engage in the idea
not to accept the premise John Stewart's
mind the news had become an arms race to
become more sensational as fantastic
than the rest but it resulted in a loss
of fidelity of what is important
just like the loudness wars the
sensationalist wars were obliterating
the crescendos of real-life news by
amplifying everything into
meaninglessness and now we come back to
the excitement Wars all of these guys
are emotional actors playing to what
they know that we want but just like in
media and news it's getting to the point
where we can no longer distinguish what
is actually fun and exciting because
people play everything up as if it were
so exciting but maybe we don't have to
accept the premise here's something to
remember these wars eventually get
played out
people get sick of the escalation and
insanity of it and we can see these
effects happening in the loudness wars
where we've seen a reduction in over
compression since 2005 we've also seen a
similar reaction in the sensationalist
wars with the rise in popularity of
websites like politifact fact-check and
all sides that seek to lessen the
sensationalism in politics and seek
unbias we will never be rid of people
trying to exploit our biases whether it
be towards volume sensationalism or
excitement but thankfully we can vote
with our views to not pay attention to
those people these wars are going to
keep going but we don't have to be a
part of it
[Music]
hey thanks for watching that video we
just hit 10,000 subscribers in this
channel which is completely amazing I
never thought I would be there and
thanks so much to those of you who have
been sharing my videos liking them
commenting on them that just means so
much to the channel and really helps my
channel grow I try not to use clickbait
or too much like kind of tricks so I
really rely on you guys to get the word
out there kind of organically so thank
you so much to those of you who have
done it and are gonna continue to do
that and yeah I hope you enjoyed that
video let me know what you want to see
next